meine große ist viel schöner als kleiner
junge war dann ist voll hässlich sein
und dann kommt er
hey leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ja da hätte
ich hoffe natürlich gibt's gute freund
euch gerade sicherlich warum hat lex
diese komische mütze auf kurze story
dahinter ich habe mir diese mütze gegen
die vor drei monaten gekauft hatte die
einen tag an und dachte dann ich habe
sie verloren sie lag einfach genau hier
hinter ganz hinten drin und ich hab sie
gerade wieder gefunden und die war so
teuer wie heute wären heute was wirklich
sehr krasses spezielles vor
das gute ist in köln hat es geschneit
das schlechte ist der schnee ist fast
schon wieder weg aber ein bisschen
schnee ist noch da auf jeden fall habe
ich gerade einmal diese perücke besorgt
und pinken lippenstift und wir sind
wirklich auf die bescheuerte idee kommen
und zwar ist es war schon dunkel
aber wir gehen das doch raus und suchen
uns eine stelle und schneemann bauen
können und wofür brauchen wir das hier
und zwar ganz einfach wir bauen jetzt
katja ins meer
es ist wieder die holst die idee
überhaupt hält ja ich hoffe natürlich
das gelingt uns noch und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim zuschauen
ich will gar nicht eingeladen also leute
lasst schon mal nach oben dafür die
coole idee und vision vielleicht so
leute wir müssen jetzt logischerweise
erstmal coolen platz finden wo
einigermaßen gutes licht ist und ich
glaube wir fahren jetzt zum
hallenstadion
das ist die forderung die denke dass
ganz cool kurzer fun fact köln hat heute
wieder 43 verloren nachdem sie 13 uhr
geführt haben sehr gut
in dem musik
das ist
heute schaut euch einfach mal das wetter
am ohne spaß ich bin vor einer stunde
noch draußen gewesen und es lag alles
voll mit schnee und jetzt ist einfach
die komplette schneefans werk ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie es dahinter aussieht ob
es sowieso noch schnee liegt wir werden
sehen nur was machen wir wenn kein
schnee mehr da ist dann fahren wir
einfach irgendwelche leute wir sind
jetzt angekommen hier am stadion oder
wie man sieht es ist übelst kassam
regnen wie schnell der ganze schnee
einfach weg ist also wir gucken jetzt wo
wir hinfahren weil wir wollen auf jeden
fall noch diesen schneemannbauen haben
gerade schon zehn verhilft aber ich
meine eher wenig zu tun
leute ihr könnt mich gerade nicht sehen
aber wir sind in schleiden
wir waren gerade in ohle hier ist halt
echt gar nichts
aber hier liegt schnee
perfekter schnee so wir fahren jetzt
irgendwo im nirgendwo zu dem netto
parkplatz hoffen dass da stehen wir sind
jetzt angekommen hier heißt es jetzt
weiß ich ob man zieht aber es schneit
hier sogar ein bisschen also wir sind
echt ziemlich hoch und wir haben hier
ist richtig viel schnee also es reicht
zumindest
wollen wir ein riesen macht diesen katja
machen
die brust also leute der erste alles
fertig von ganz vielen händen okay leute
weiter geht's
so leicht mittelteil von katja ist auch
fertig jetzt kommt noch ein kopf
oberkörper sword druck jetzt fehlt noch
der kopf und die accessoires
ich habe die kamera jetzt aufs auto
gestellt wir machen weiter so leute der
kopf ist fertig leute schaut euch das an
ein wunderschöner schneemann richtig
schön hier ein abgeschliffen sobald man
stimmen jetzt fehlt noch das gesicht mit
den dicken lippen
die brüste viel noch und die haare will
den arschbacken machen was machst du da
ja auch mal weitermachen meint aber
diese noch zu klein
nein dann ist voll hässlich nein wir
gehen das ganz kurz steine suchen
wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwelche sehen
würde die würden bestimmt denken wir
wollen das netto einbrechen wollen wir
nicht juli ist jetzt gerade da hinten
und tuffstein hasse steine gefunden
nach ersten wir erstmal die augen machen
sagen was das macht macht das als
ausgemacht dass auch ich habe die decke
das war halt mal kurz das war heute ganz
wichtig was haben wir denn hier immer
erst die lücke mit dem vorderen teil
da passt so ist im mund komplett rechts
ja dass das wird natürlich kein normaler
schneemann freue mich denken wieso die
leute die hier morgen einkaufen gehen
was denken die nicht mit der anderen
seite muss die blätter da so rein
drücken einfach solche die blätter
kommen jetzt noch rein und dann gibt es
würde ich mal sagen ein kleines
schneemann poren also keinen kap horn
auch wenn das ziemlich geil aussieht da
vorne wir machen jetzt ein schneemann
fort so ein diamant bauchnabel piercing
ist jetzt auch noch da und ob sie
da kommt er ich habe die kamera
ausgemacht leider also irgendwie aus
reflex man das war ein bisschen blöd
aber ohne witz irgendwie hat das ja
angerufen oder fällt wahrscheinlich da
haben nicht so einfach so aber muss
sagen die waren mega cool und ich glaube
die haben echt gedacht wir wollen ja
einbringen so wie es gesagt habe ist ja
auch verdächtigt aber sowas müssen er
meinte der schneemann ist ein bisschen
sexuell anzüglich dann muss man den weg
machen
also ich habe in meinen kanal angesagt
wenn sie das sehen schöne grüße sie
waren folgende frage mich glaubt und
haben gedacht hat irgendwie das auto
geklaut oder so weil die mine
warum fährt man in unserem jungen alter
schon so ein auto kann man da mal den
fahrzeugschein sehen irgendwie voll
gestört aber es war witzig ist ja noch
was passiert heute haben scheiße sind
dann so lange gefahren
aber wir haben gleich schnell haben wir
haben polizisten erklärt was also die
polizei kennt jetzt auch katja und ja an
die polizei noch einmal geboren den sex
wird anzüglichen schneemann die jetzt
kommt aber der schneemann toren und
polizei kommt
so leute und da die polizei ja gesagt
hat wir dürfen das hier nicht so stehen
lassen und haben auf unsere personalien
jetzt leider zu stören viel spaß
denn
so leute wie es geht wir haben jetzt
schon den nächsten tag wir sind
logischerweise wieder zu hause ich
glaube wir sind so ungefähr und 3 julian
gekommen war echt ein ziemlich cooler
trip auch an dieser stelle nochmals
schöne grüße an die polizei man müsse
natürlich klar dass man uns bei den
bengel da auch mal kontrollieren muss
zentrale wir haben jetzt zwei lausbuben
die einen schneemann bauen können immer
bitte checken ob die nicht vorbestraft
sind an dieser stelle werde ich das
wieder gefallen lassen auf jeden fall
nach oben da schon auch bei jugend
vorbei der hat auch mir gemacht das
ganze bestimmung verlinkt laster auf
jeden fall aber da und was auch noch
ganz wichtig ist ich weiß nicht ob er
das video gestern gesehen haben und zwar
wort gestern im video wieder was verlost
dieser lockenstab von den gleisen
diese speisen von die super geil also da
kann ich euch nur sagen schaut mal
vorbei weil im video von gestern macht
mit und ja die ganzen gewinner von den
ganzen sachen werden dann am 26 dezember
verkündet vieles ist aber noch nicht
verraucht zum beispiel die action kennen
die playstation das iphone diese
vorteile oder wie ich müsste mich jetzt
erstmal ins zeug legen als würde ich
sagen soll morgen ein paar aus dem video
wir sind mal wieder morgen 19 uhr und ja
so viel von mir
3 schönen abend noch